hello uh mr p luigi this is manish i am
at i'm the student at mit scm program
here
i'm i belong to india and i've been
working in fmcg sector in india for
quite some time before this program okay
in which company have you i was working
with amv there okay and the
very good yes
hi my name is dorine perez i'm from
venezuela i'm taking the gc log program
here at mit
i moved to miami three months ago so
right now i
can answer
the name of a company i'm working for
because i'm not
but i used to work in a cemetery back in
venezuela very good now which
mit will be based in miami not in boston
the initials would be the same actually
yeah
hello my name is i come from greece
and i am studying in the mit saragosa
logistics program that is based in
sarawak and europe so i am more focused
on the european market
and the european
in general
perception i have studied civil
engineering this is my background but
the past few years i was working in the
family business that has to do with
customs clearance
customs brokerage and freight forwarding
back in greece very good and nice to
meet you nice to meet you
yeah mr luigi so uh i'm dutchin and i'm
actually from singapore um i'm taking
the mit program over in shaa allah
malaysia
and before this i was doing risk
management market risk management um
golden agri resources
we work very closely with them one of
our suppliers and partners
out of indonesia yeah
very good
so we thank you for your talk a while
ago and actually some of the
things that you would want to ask are
linked to what you already spoke about
so i'll start with something which is
very close to your heart sustainability
and unilever
uh as you just mentioned there was a
time when sustainability and what you
need to do as a company versus what
business needs with respect to the
growth
came together and you made a plan which
goes together rather than in
contrast to each other i still would
want to ask there would be some
experience that you would have with
respect to
if i call that tension
or uh you know dialogue argument with
respect to
spending on a green initiative versus
the benefits that it will get the
company there has to be that learning
curve
so what are how did you push your agenda
with respect to sustainability
initiatives in that
and whether you would say critical mass
that unilever has has helped you in
doing that yes
so to to start with the latter
absolutely the size of unilever is uh
relevant in many markets where we
operate not only from a finnish
product's point of view but also what we
buy and that size for instance in palm
oil has been quite a key factor for us
to create a movement in the industry to
allow and to engage many companies to
source palm oil sustainably
to your question about the tension
between cost and uh and sustainability i
have to admit that it not only not
always works uh to buy green pile
certificates today you have to pay
premiums
and that doesn't necessarily help your
your your p l
equation but in the holistic way in
which we manage our business we generate
enough savings to offset
those additional costs
and at the same time those savings are
coming also from other sustainability
initiatives so when we start reducing
the amount of waste that we have in our
operations when we start reducing the
logistics
distances that we travel
when we start reducing the manufacturing
use of energy
these are all
investments that we make that help the
cost structure of our business that also
allows us to actually pay more for some
specific commodities as long as this is
for us
definitely a concise amount of time
and the totality of the equation for us
has been always very positive so
sustainability for unilever is is a way
of doing business
it's not a project
it's not
what companies believe is corporate
social responsibility it's a new
business model that we're handling and
as such we believe we can double the
size of our business
while being more profitable as a company
and reducing the carbon footprint was to
increase the social impact that we have
out there can we say that
since the company takes green
initiatives
as a core as a culture it triggers a lot
more concentration and focus on getting
cost out in various different areas to
in a way fulfill
and
ensure that the p l still is helpful
absolutely
we all believe that this is a mission
that we have
in corporate life
and also as individuals and as such
every every person
works in small actions that can make a
big difference
so whether it's in a factory in on a
specific line where the operator is
mindful about the kind of energy that is
using whether it is an r d scientist
that is redesigning our products that it
will use less packaging materials
whether it is
our strategies that is redefined in our
manufacturing network we all believe
that one way or another
we can redesign the way in which we run
on our operations
by providing cost benefits and at the
same time reducing our carbon footprint
and that has become the way of doing
business for us
uh yeah mr luigi so i think i've got a
follow-up question uh
on the same team
so um
okay you mentioned in a presentation
that uh
you know unilever is a role model
attempting to influence
competitors and to a certain extent
suppliers to actually
become sustainable
i think one of the obstacles would be
that
profitability
is easy to measure but
uh the benefits from sustainability are
somewhat more difficult to quantify
so um how have you actually
dealt with this problem and also i guess
the next thing is um how have you
actually influenced competitors to
actually become sustainable
so
first of all the benefits of
sustainability
are
not necessarily
difficult to quantify
if you know how to measure your
end-to-end carbon footprint for instance
as a business
whether it's in the use of water whether
it's in the release of greenhouse gases
i mean we have enough know-how
and and engaging with the academic world
to actually measure that and as such
our initiatives are publicly stated in
our website
they're audited by external parties
because we we do have them in our annual
reports
and you can see
you know across all the different
dimensions which are more than 40 how we
do measure those benefits along the
lines of social environmental business
practices
so
we engage with competitors in a way that
they they can only
see the the benefit
of doing this
together with us without necessarily
conflicting on interests
the consumer good forum is one
organization where all the ceos from our
sector get together and they discuss uh
what is what the the whole industry can
do in the sustainability environment
and
as such
there are commitments that we make there
to to stop sourcing
from suppliers that are deforestating
for instance which are is just an
example of areas where we don't compete
and we can collaborate
we engage together or or indirectly with
ngos
who will also bring to our attention and
to their attention some of the practices
that we need to change
so whether it's directly or indirectly
we we must collaborate not only with
other private sector members but also
with the public sector as well and it's
only by creating public and private
partnerships
governments civil society and other
companies that we can create that
movement that will start changing the
way in which we do business and setting
new standards so at the end we can
change the world and that's what we're
doing today yeah
i had a question about how you assure
that once the products are on customer
hands they will use them and they will
disposing
them in a way that is responsible
however earlier today that you mentioned
that you have working less packaging
less use of liquids when they need to
use a product like soap for example
and also
less temperature need
to wash clothes or
so i want to twist the question a little
and ask you for example with products in
aerosol presentations that are
let's say difficult to dispose
do you are you planning some kind of
reverse logistic do you have any plans
for that i know lush which is a personal
care brand
they
promote customers to bring back
their the packaging and for each five
packaging that they they return they
will give one
uh free item so
reverse logistics are always very
complicated too and i think that's a
pretty easy way so what are you planning
about that
there is no way we can
do this with a big impact by ourselves
so yes we do engage with our customers
the retailers are there
um to ensure that somehow
it is in their interest and in our
interest to recycle more products there
are also industry associations which are
created on purpose like for pet for
instance that are quite advanced in that
sense and there is an economic value
there that has sustained that sector
that recyclability that we see today
so it is absolutely important that we do
design products that are recyclable
and not that can only be disposed to the
environment
that is a case of aluminum as you
mentioned on your question
where
there is clearly a value in the residual
component of the aerosol once is used
and
and the industry itself has developed
well enough to allow recycled aluminum
to be used
in in other sectors and even in our
products as well which i think is is one
of the elements of that circular economy
that is slowly but surely being
developed out there today
on our hand there is also a big
commitment to start investing on
technologies that will allow
microeconomies to be developed in the
developing markets for instance in such
as or flexible materials to be
reprocessed so you can generate fuel out
of those or regenerate against polyphen
in a way that can be used in our
factories or it can be reused in our
products so
we do design our products to reduce the
amount of material to reuse it somehow
in a way that at the end the holistic
value of that equation remains
sustainable we're not hundred percent
there yet because some of those
equations are not economically feasible
but we are investing a lot in this sense
because we do believe that
there is value for us and there is value
obviously for our
planet if more companies do so
a word consumer education educating
consumer would be a key piece there or
is you never doing something on that
yeah we we don't feel to be so arrogant
as to use the word educating consumers
what we do is to create the conditions
for them to see the value
of
of recyclability
when you deal with a lady that is doing
her laundry in in the south of india you
know that for her
the environment is not as important as
it is her family
and and it does in those locations where
we redesign our products so she can see
the convenience of using less water so
she has to walk less to to get the water
out of the well that is in the town or
even hours away from where she lives
so for her sustainability is about using
less water spending less time
having the high quality products that
will allow her to fulfill the family
needs
and although we don't communicate
sustainability for her but only
convenience at the end is an equation
i've seen those
in our television back in back home so
that's part of what i called education
so exactly
so okay i would like to ask you about uh
you mentioned before
that
there are some initiatives and some
efforts in reducing the energy use
during the manufacturing process for the
production of the brothers
could you mention some
measures in order to
become more efficient in terms of energy
absolutely
using less energy reducing energy
from electricity for heating or
what exactly do you do in your plants
yeah so two answers to your question
first is the kind of energy we use and
second is how we use it the kind of
energy can be from renewable or
non-renewable sources
27 of the energy that we use in unilever
today in our industrial system comes
from renewable sources which is wind
solar
water and so on geothermal energy do you
use any any geothermal energy coming
from yes absolutely yes so
we have
combined heat and and
and
and energy production uh technologies in
our factories um we have uh boilers
which are uh actually
producing energy out of biomass and not
necessarily from non-renewable fuel
fossils
and that is a trend that we have
started where we're aiming at least to
reach 40 of the total of the energy that
we use in unilever that can come from
from renewable sources of generation so
you got in front of eu
that has in front of european union that
has set the 20 20 20 target for 2020 so
we are using
77 yes already around the world you are
aiming to 40
yes so every every new factor that we we
create and we have opened about 30 25
factors until last year and 33 in total
in 2015 in the last five years
has the mission to actually reduce at
least by half
the kind of greenhouse gases and carbon
footprint that it generates so we're
investing in new technologies that are
making our manufacturing process much
more efficient and at the same time is
helping the environment so that's an and
equation where you can you can invest
capital better technologies lower use of
energy lower cost a more profitable
business
now on the other hand it's also about
how we use the energy and that in that
sense
we have embarked in a program that is
quite amazing because we are now having
sensors and meters along every single of
the lines that we have in many of our
factories that are providing the
visibility to our engineers of the
amount of water and the amount of energy
that we use so they're much more aware
and conscious that in many times of the
year when there is no production you can
minimize the use of energy or the
disposal of water that alone has
generated a significant amount of
reduction of use of energy
so the question is
use and sources and cost and when you
can reduce
you can make them renewable and when you
can actually
buy them at a lower cost you end up
having a great equation once again that
helps the environment and helps your
business at the same time
also i would like to ask something about
the
social
responsibility
you said that you are
trying to source environmentally
friendly raw materials and also from
suppliers that do not use child abuse
child labor or women abuse
but how can you trace back um
the suppliers if we are talking about
forced tire or third tire supplier so
supplier or the supplier of your direct
supplier
how do you trace
back the supply chain in order to find
whether he uses or
child labor or
abuse of children or women yeah very
very good question and very difficult to
answer to be honest
we have about 10 000 suppliers
that are only engaged in raw and
packaging materials if you start looking
for services and other areas is hundreds
of thousands so
um it is almost uh materially impossible
to measure the third and even seconds
sometimes second third 40th of the
suppliers that our suppliers use
but we have engaged with them in what we
call a responsible sourcing program
where they have committed to work with
us
in uh in setting the standards which
along the lines of the united nations
human rights for for for businesses
which is called the the rocky framework
sponsored by the united nations and it
is in that framework where we have asked
our key partners and our suppliers to
commit
to this program as a way to have a
business with us
so we empower them
and we randomly also check
whether they are actually respecting
these these new standards and of course
it's not easy to do
we have found cases of human slavery
indirectly linked to some of our
customers still
or our suppliers as well we have stopped
doing businesses with them every time
there is evidence that is brought by
any organization
that
you know verifies the fact that the
human rights are not being respected
we first investigate and validate those
sources and if that is the case we
actually engage directly with the
supplier to say this is not how we do
business
if you don't stop immediately these
these practices we're going to stop
doing business with you and we engage
with them in what i really call an
educational program in some cases
whether it's linked to social impact or
human rights or environmental practices
is something that we feel very proactive
to do
in our countries there is a common uh
response when someone proposed a green
project because they don't see the
benefit economic benefit although they
see it as an unnecessary cost
what advice will you give us
in order for us to go there and change
that mindset yeah
yeah but first of all we do believe that
we are in a in a stage of our history
today where the cost of doing nothing is
actually higher than the cost of
investing for a better planet
climate change is creating a significant
amount of disruption in the way
companies do business today
and that has become so evident that it
has
actually uh represented a must and a new
way of doing business for many many many
companies
um
you uh you have surely read about the
cop 20 event in lima which happened only
a few weeks ago
where many governments have now engaged
in and committed to
new targets to protect the planet in in
the long term i personally don't believe
there is enough time
for us to act
is possibly very late
but
we have to keep working very hard on
this to to make people understand that
unless
they change the way in which they set
their policies uh we bring evidence in
terms of cost
and and also the damage this creates for
governments for civil society
nothing will happen
uh the good news is that a movement is
is
is there and i can see more and more and
more news which are encouraging us for
the future uh but you have as much as i
do a big responsibility in your
shoulders to ask the right questions to
challenge the right organizations to
work for a company that you can feel is
truly committed to to this
to this space because at the end it's
about your future as i said before
10 20 years ago we were telling each
other this was for the next generation
today this is for us this is not for for
our children anymore so unless we do
something about it uh we're going to pay
the consequences for this okay
mr pioluji um i've got a question
regarding
supply chain curious about something
you mentioned during the presentation
that um you know there are some
challenges that you face
but at the same time you have got a
great team
so all of these challenges that you face
uh would that be one or two that tend to
occupy
more of your mind space or that you tend
to pay more attention to because of
whatever reasons and yeah
i occupied my mind um
in in understanding how to make our
business more successful
as a member of the executive board
and i believe that's
one of my many responsibilities
but i do also occupied a lot of my time
and my mind in
talking to my team members in
discussing with them how
how they're doing what can i do to help
and create the right environment for
them to exploit their potential
they come to me only when they need help
i hate micromanaging people
for me my role is more an inspiring role
and a leadership role than a manager
role
and as such i do expect to be called
when they need guidance when they need
support when they need advice and where
they need to share their wins and their
failures
and it is in that space where i have my
biggest rewards
because i do see people feeling
passionate and inspired by
the the way i work with them
and that is
such a virtual circle that allows you to
grow as an individual as your people
grow as well
so
i do believe that in order to succeed as
a leader you have to invest time
in training your people so they can
leave the company one day
but at the same time treat them so well
that they never want to leave
and that's what i do every day just
talking about
business success
we have seen a lot of economic turmoil
in the past few years and
unilever's strategy has been
focused on emerging markets
more than
obviously saturated markets in developed
markets
now we're seeing things like china
countries like china india brazil as
well slowing down from what they were
and unilever if i'm not wrong the
strategy has been to
open factories on their own more often
than not so you have already put in
capex already put in uh some commodity
management practices
at the scale that you are i'm uh so my
question is whether that these economies
that that are like stagnating
like europe japan us and d growth in
india china brazil
how does that impact your apex decisions
whether amortizations are a problem do
you think these needs to be managed at
your level at an executive level
obviously and is there a change in the
supply chain setup that you see has to
happen now absolutely then
that's a real great question
so so first of all we make investments
for the long term
um when we open a new factory we don't
do it for like three to five years but
we do it for 20 30 40 years if no more
we we do still today celebrate factors
that were open about 125 years ago
and so our commitment when we put
capital is for the long term
now economies go in cycles and clearly
you have to adjust the way in which you
deploy capex so you don't create an
additional burden in your cost structure
when your volumes come down and your
turnover your cells don't go as expected
so we we calibrate that so until last
year we were investing between four to
four and a half percent of our sales
into capital expenditure
we have publicly said
that
in the current economic climate this is
not necessarily
affordable anymore so we have brought
those investments down on a range
between three and a half to four percent
and as such we're now monitoring more
capacity globally that's a good example
of where you leverage scale
we ask ourselves twice do we need this
capacity can we leverage this by relying
on the availability in other markets so
we can export more between countries so
we have adjusted the way in which we
allocate more capacity uh in light of
this economic slowdown but remain very
true to ourselves that if we have to
grow in africa for instance and we need
to open six new factories we would do so
in a sort of intelligent way but without
necessarily thinking that there is no
future in these markets the demographics
uh the economic conditions and the
growth potential is so big that even
though there is a slight slowdown
we believe we're building competitive
advantage by investing today for
tomorrow
so
in terms of capacity as you mentioned
you
i i could say from what you said that
you invest more in flexibility
in your plants
and your product lines rather than on
increasing the capacity in overall
is that the case
no actually
it depends of the product category and
the portfolio that we produce so when
you're dealing with
sort of commoditized categories like
home care powders for instance you want
to maximize your capacity at the
possible highest level
and because your your margins or your
cost equation is very thin
so at the end you need to really squeeze
your assets as much as possible
when you deal with high margin products
you want to keep capacity available
because not selling them not having
enough capacity to produce creates more
damage to your margins
than optimizing your cost equation alone
so it's a strategy that we do in a
product category by product category
level if the products travel
we end up relying on capacity more
regionally or globally if they don't
travel we invest locally and we try to
keep the capacity available in a way
that
our products are always on the shelf
because we grow as a business if our own
shelf availability is there
i
also would like to ask something about
the food product category
and how do you respond to the changing
diet habits
the past few years towards more healthy
lifestyles
towards biological food products
do you consider changing your products
to become
apart from environmental and socially
friendly also
follow the trend
like biological food or
food that has less cholesterol or
i mean the chemical composition yes
so we're working we're working very part
of our sustainable living plan also
includes
the importance and the need to
reformulate our products so we can make
them much healthier just to give an
example in ice cream for instance for
children we have publicly committed not
to have any ice cream that has more than
100 calories for instance we have
reduced significant amount of salt
and
and other non-healthy ingredients in our
products in a way that they can also be
value and good for consumers we do
believe margarine has a much
healthier profile than butter for
instance
and as such we we keep supporting that
business
so
being having a sustainable business also
means having a sustainably and healthy
portfolio and that's what we're doing
right now uh in terms of biological or
not
there are there there the very different
points of view in that sense people
believe that organic means healthier i
personally only personally believe
that's wrong i believe that
that's a
fallacy and a change that will happen
soon when people will start
understanding that the fact that is
organic doesn't mean anything uh
compared to a product that is produced
more under the standards of the past
but we we do at the end what consumers
want us to do because at the end we're
here to serve them and we can only grow
if they appreciate our portfolio and if
they want non-gmo in our products we'll
have non-gmo in our products if they
don't care and we believe that's
something that helps the agricultural
practices and reduces less
less of the use of resources then we'll
use gmo depending on those conditions
and i wanted to ask now that we're
talking about changes in different
markets and the challenges
how has unilever
face the challenges of its business in
venezuela since we have all these
obstacles like
exchange control supply limitations
workforce limitations
i'm sure that your supply chains have to
make big changes in order to face that
and to still be in the market you have
an ice cream market there that i
understand it's amazing
yeah what what have you done in unity
ever
to face that
so in the past we used to rely more on a
regional supply chain for venezuela
which
was making our business much more
profitable
we realized that that was not a
sustainable way of doing business so
we have started using more local
third-party manufacturers
to be more locally present because the
demand is quite significant
the currency value is devastating and
the inflation rates are very concerning
but we're committed to venezuela for the
long term as much as we were committed
to indonesia when sugar was in power and
today we have a very powerful business
over there so the the strength of
unilever is that we do define strategies
for the long term and we don't
opportunistically enter and exit the
market based on political conditions
now it is tough to do business in
venezuela today
but we do believe that by investing
locally we can have a much more
successful
business and your example on ice cream
is the best one where we're now opening
a new factory in venezuela believe it or
not that will allow us to grow by
multiples our ice cream business that
has a beautiful brand and that's just an
example of how much we're committed for
the long term
just
nothing to do with the
what is the sense of driving a formula
one or a lamborghini as you mentioned
before
because i love speed that's why but yes
i've never had a chance only bikes only
fast bikes yeah more affordable
so i i like i like motor racing for for
for two reasons one is because it's a
very competitive environment and you
truly learn
um what it takes to win
in uh in uh in an environment where
a second makes all the difference and
it's actually quite a big amount of time
so it is about being extreme in your
competitive levels but also excelling
thanks to
an amazing individual talent that the
pilot has on one side but also
an incredible amount of teamwork that is
behind whoever is is raising the car
and that combination in my view is
something that you can also apply to
business and it can be very inspiring
for many not only for those who are fans
of this formula one environment but also
those who really want to
learn what it takes to win
so
i i was born with a passion to win and
and for me
racing it's all about
exposing yourself it's about
learning
your weaknesses it's about
investing and training on developing
your own skills
and that is something that you will have
to apply and you're doing today in mit
but you have to keep doing that in every
single day of your life
it also helps you to remain humble
because there are always others who are
much better than you
and you can always win in life if you
learn from your mistakes
if you learn from the understanding of
what is what you you need to learn and
what you need to do in order to be a
better pilot a better professional and
it's in that sense that uh i always say
to myself
that you have to expose to
areas of
your
word and my word that make you very
uncomfortable because it's only there
that you grow as an individual when you
do things for the first time when you
feel that you're getting yourself
outside your own comfort box
and when you do that you end up learning
that
you have a lot much more to do
and it's by committing to yourself and
your long-term future that you can
actually be a much better professional
so
that word gives me a lot of lessons
and and i believe that is one of uh very
inspiring sectors where we learn how to
do better business but also have fun
and at the end life is very short and we
have to do things that we like to do
in order to be happy for the long term
thank you thank you
thanks again
thank you thank you very much all the
best thanks
thank you thank you nice to meet you